first to I think we should be a we
should be pretty happy with shhh
standard use of product or standard use
of quotient rule I hope they are looking
ok for you you can see by the way I hope
you can see why you know how sometimes I
back yeah the form you put it in not
that big a deal particularly out of
product rule but do you see why I wasn't
happy to leave that do you see why she's
just a tee it's just a teeny bit it's a
teeny bit ambiguous like what is that is
that sine of 2x squared late is it sine
x times 2x or is it sine of x times 2x
and even though I heard my brackets for
myself that's what I was doing um but I
wasn't that happy with it and I could
take a factor out so I did okay now part
3 who agrees x derivative heads up do
you see what I did you see what I did
clearly clearly this is trying to give
you a curveball and think our logs okay
I might write that as 2 X minus 3 to the
negative 1 and then launch it the chain
rule which you should be able to do but
clearly that's less efficient than
picking o log laws loblaws now maybe
have you seen this question first it
would a bit a bit more obvious to you
hey work with your primitive first
before you get to the derivative because
differentiation especially when you have
to do chain rule product or question
rule is intense it's computationally
intense simplify is computationally easy
that's kind of why it's got simplifying
right so do that as much of that as you
can first in this case that was used to
vlog laws here to render it you know you
don't need to use chain rule really like
proper proper trade rule of chain rule
you don't have to use it so much okay so
you see how I got that and then platform
of course she used to divide through
okay you could render it back either for
that it was given to you and I've give
this a fracture but I don't think
there's any need a depressing need for
that okay here's my integral it's pretty
straightforward actually if you wanted
to you could take the third out and put
the three in like I
did but if you did it that's okay so
long as you landed at the right spot
okay now let's have a look at this
contentious integral yeah yep so this is
an extension one quiz so I'm not going
to worry about that you don't get them
up get marked down for it but you don't
need to include that clearly the crux of
my proof is the graph but the graph is
everything to me okay so really most of
my mental effort was invested in getting
the graph right and then the algebra
ends up relatively trivial of course is
another way through this which doesn't
require a graph at all what would you do
you could you could take this here and
because it's an inequality you can't
just multiply by 2 x minus 1 why not
because 2x minus 1 be that X is a
variable 2x minus 1 is also variable it
can change sign so therefore it gives
you cases so to avoid that you would
multiply our both sides by whoa I'm not
highlighting that's not what I want I'm
you would multiply both sides by 2 X
minus 1 squared okay now when you do
that you have to be careful right
because doing so will eliminate the
denominator from your question that's
kind of the point right but when you
lose the denominator you lose some
information from the question what do
you lose yeah you lose the fact that
wait there's a discontinuity right so
you turn up this problem you turn it
into a quadratic but there's a hole and
so that's why you can see right there
you shouldn't be at that boundary and
that's cuz the original function has
that asymptote there okay now I maybe
you've heard me say this a lot right I
clearly think that the graphical way is
better you've gotta know how to graph
these things so let me just quickly if
you didn't choose that path or maybe you
chose it but something went wrong let me
walk you through mentally what I did to
get back laughs okay let's start at the
beginning the easy things to see that if
you have a look at this denominator down
here that gives you the vertical
asymptote right away okay so there you
go I've popped him in that's food when
you then say okay I've got that
asymptote I know roughly speaking that
this whole
this whole rational function here should
be a hyperbola or some kind because I've
seen these all before right so therefore
I say look I need to compare these two
guys right I need to compare the leading
terms of the numerator and the
denominator the degrees are the same so
then what do i do from there I divide
through right because as X approaches
the extremities the positive positive
and negative infinity okay you're going
to get four billion over two million and
for Billy it over to billions so you're
getting 4 over 2 and that's where my
terribly scaled horizontal asymptote
comes from okay so there's that value so
now I've got my asymptotes and then I
have to think about well is it going to
be these two branches that I've got here
or is it going to be for instance these
two branches which I didn't draw now
what's a quick way that can help you
work out it's the correct one that when
I've draw it rather than one in purple
yeah the way intercept is really easy to
find right all you have to do you say x
equals zero right which in this case
happens to be very advantageous to you
because that's an important point you're
putting in x equals 0 so these two terms
that I was looking before disappear so
you've got negative 3 over negative 1
and that's your point up there which
actually saves you a bit of effort I did
the working just to show that if it
might not have been so convenient you
might not have gotten 0 x equals 3
that's actually the boundary value I
want maybe in more cases the arm this
intercept here which tells you where the
graph goes that'll be some other value
in which case you've got to do this
right now I do think it's it's incumbent
on you to say I'm doing something
different now right because you have God
from here whoops to a lion which is a
very different problem right it's
related obviously but you're not solving
the same thing and lots of students
don't demonstrate that they understand
there's a distinction so I tell you I
make it obvious I'm doing something
different now I go ahead and solve
there's my boundary value and then I say
look from the graph I want to be below 3
so that you can see I kind of stuck
myself on like that on the scale that's
obviously not my wife Kristi should be
but I'd already drawn my why does after
that point sounds like whatever it
it's just to help me understand the
shape of it okay so I want this
component over here because it's
underneath and then I don't even think
about the rest this entire component has
to be part has to solve it because it's
only three right so I just say this is
the part I got from the boundary value
and in this part all of that is beneath
too so it must also satisfy okay are you
happy with the way that I proceeded
through with my logic okay graphing is
powerful get comfortable with a graph
for you not long to go down okay right
shree move on to the last question ok
now just before we do this I was just
having a quick skim of the room before I
am close that off and I don't think I
mean I didn't see everyone's but i don't
think i saw a single solution that was
mine and most people had different
solutions so there are many many paths
through this question I don't even know
if the path I've got is the quickest 1
i'd love to see if someone could could
beat the one that I've got but this I
think is pretty straight forward to it
you have to think very carefully before
you put pen to paper obviously because
you don't want to just go in some random
direction and have all this algebra
written and equations written down
you're like where am I going ok so here
is the shape thereafter s l M hey so
this is what we want to be a rhombus ok
now when you think about this and
admittedly oh it's been a while since
I've done this what's the quickest way
or what are some of the quick ways to
prove that something is a rhombus yeah
it's ok so diagonals bisecting it right
now because I just pause for a second I
would not be surprised if a lot of you
tried in that direction because just
think for a moment what would it mean
how would I proved with coordinate
geometry that the diagonals bisect and
are at right angles I need two piece of
information oops
yes Shh let me show it to graphically
okay if I like them to wake up if I want
them to let's take a lot of time let's
talk about the mutually bisecting okay
so here is what diagonal and here is the
other you could do a whole buttload of
distances if you really want it but the
faster way is to say if the midpoint of
woe is the midpoint of the other that
means they mutually bisect thumbs up
okay then you need them to be not just
mutually bisecting if the diagonals
bisect what could it be it could be well
I rectangle is yeah it's not it's not a
rhombus is it's close okay I could be a
square the squares even better though so
therefore I've got to go further and
I've got to show that okay no because it
could be one of these guys so well
that's terrible a kite has diagonals
that bisect at right angles sorry they
intersect at right angles there is one
that bisects you've got this guy but the
other one is not yeah so I kite is asked
washed over on this so what you need is
both of those and that's a good way to
go because midpoints easy to calculate
gradients also pretty easy to calculate
so that's a good part through this
question okay yes sir there's things
that get better give it to you now
interestingly when I looked at this I
noticed so where s and P are because I
knew where s and P are M&L are also
quite easy to find you notice that
because they're vertically beneath right
so you don't have to do very much
argument at all you can just say well
look at let's have a look at em right if
you have a look at em you can say I know
what its x-coordinate is because i just
read it from that guy above and it's on
the directrix so BAM right all I did you
say in fact you can see you can sort of
see the way I've started the solution
okay and in the same way L is super easy
okay it is the y-intercept of this line
that line there so you just read off y
equals MX plus B that's going to be zero
yep okay so knowing that I've got these
points okay you would have had to get
those to get your mid points and so on
but if I've got those and I also notice
that these are vertical I think I might
be able to do this quicker so I'd like
you to do a comparison with me I got x
coordinates and I went this way okay I
got the gradients rather than the
gradients of bio diagonals I took the
gradients of the two sides that weren't
vertical okay I looked at I looked at
this side and this side I found their
gradients okay the reason I went for
them is because the other two sides the
ones I've marked in parallel lines for
red there boy with vertical that's part
of the question so no arguments required
so if i can get the orange part right
that means this is already are
parallelogram and to get from a
parallelogram to a rhombus is super
super easy parallelograms have two pairs
of opposite science to that up sides
equal so all you need to do is show that
the pairs are also equal to each other
and look at this if you have a look
right the two adjacent sides that you
want what they are are a marketing green
do this guy here which is this sense to
the focus and this guy here which is the
distance to the directrix which by the
lockers definition of a parabola are
equal so I have a parallelogram that has
adjacent sides equal which means all of
the sides equal so I have my Robin